Chris Webber Hall of Famer Turner Sports
artery analyst and host of the NBA TV's
players only which premieres tonight
with LeBron James against the Spurs he
will be on the call for Celtics Thunder
matchup TNT starting at 8:00 Eastern he
also called LeBrons debut game in
Portland Thursday night along with
Golden State season opener last Tuesday
a busy man and c-webb joining us hey
Chris how are you okay did the NBA get
it right with the suspensions in the
Lakers rockets fight I think pretty much
so I guess you know I didn't see
anything wrong with it I thought maybe
Chris Paul could have got another game
or maybe not have another game because
you know in sports I think it's very
unfair to ask a guy not to retaliate
like that's just not in the human psyche
so to me when a guy like you know fog is
2-piece for spitting on whatever happens
happen and you know he's going after a
guy to me that's just natural so I don't
think you should get a lot for going
after the guy that that initially did
you so I don't have any policy
suspension I don't think probably Rondo
any of those other guys do either when
they let those and they start letting
the pawns come out they knew what they
were getting into the thing that
concerned me the most was Brandon Ingram
coming from behind this is when somebody
really gets hurt and when he took that
shot from behind I guess that's why he
got four games yeah exactly I think he
should have had the most and you know
it's so tough and I'm not trying to
condone what Brandon Ingram did I don't
know the kid never met him a day in my
life so I don't have a race in the home
you know what's in the race but I think
sometimes too that's you being young and
I remember giving speeches to guys like
if you don't get off the sidelines I'll
pay your fine you better worry about me
more than coach everybody needs to come
off the sidelines in the scrum or you
know in those were different days and
rules but you know maybe someone said
that to him true that was a veteran but
he overdid it and I think he looks back
in time he'll know that he overdid it he
wasn't even in it but if you look at the
plays before that so I didn't watch the
game live I didn't even see the fight
last
watch to the next day and saw everything
it was building up with everything that
was going on by the refs may be missing
some cause God didn't file pretty hard
and so I actually after knowing the
fight happened I could see a building up
kind of in 2029 anybody ever spit in
your face no if they did you know what
how I live my life like I know God
watches everything and then second you
know what would my father say and
therefore if man is bit in my face I
wouldn't want to deal with my father so
I would have to Wow okay what did your
dad say you got into a fight with the
Bulls I think Luc Longley what did dad
say after he got into that fight he
teased me
he was teasing me because I had a
dislocated shoulder my shoulder was so
sore
he was like you didn't want Luke to grab
that shoulder huh he might have got you
in a headlock and I was like come on he
was just busting me up about it
my father was but yeah I never really
gotten too many fights my thing was
always I'm gonna respect you and I will
win every crazy contest that's known to
man so let's not go there
like if there will not end you know like
I'm gonna lock him after couple guys all
that and so with that you just try to
play hard man and keep it moving and
hopefully you know these guys that'd be
cool laughter but it just doesn't seem
like Rondo's one to be messed with and
it seems like Chris Paul is the other
one not to be messed with so and to be
interesting as the year goes along to
see how this plays out who was the last
guy that you wanted to see square off
against you I've got one of the factory
companies really wait oh you deeply
religious preacher Terry come on those
are the ones you have to cut fifteen
times but with Terry Cummins man I was a
rookie I was talking John came into the
league you know running looking all
crazy and all that stuff and he grabbed
me out of the air one time and he was
like cuz I was gonna try jump on
everybody's like no that'll happen here
I was like wait till next time and I
remember like some veterans by
coming over to me and being like a man
let that go and he had like that old man
grand posture and I couldn't move it and
I'm trying to get away from it so I knew
like now let me leave let me leave this
guy do not work he's Chris Webber Turner
Sports NBA analyst how would you sum up
the Lakers first week or first couple of
games I know you did the game in
Portland but but what are your
expectations with this thing so I've
been getting it's so fun you know fans
people like if I just tell what I really
think and I don't think this team can
make the playoffs period I've said that
I've said it time and time again
I know LeBron is great flair don't have
to tell me how great he is but this is
the West Coast and so I'm not thinking
from a fan perspective I'm thinking from
I've said this all summer long the
Denver is going to be really good they
beat the open state last night
Utah's gonna be really good this is the
West Coast team you know let's think
about you know you know it was really
hard for LeBron to they couldn't win a
championship with him in the way the
first time like when greats get together
it's still really hard and he's the only
great with Nathan with Rondo on that
team and with no no shooting I don't see
how this team without the trade at the
trade light trade deadline does you can
zone you can go behind everybody now
what they've done is great is they've
sped up the taste last year they were
number one overall and they're still
number one with pace they play fast
they're gonna get easy layups the other
day they had like 70 point paint points
and the team career-high is like 81
paint points so I see them being really
good I've seen them playing harder than
most teams I see them winning just on
the merit of of effort but I do not see
them beating this skill these skilled
teams in the NBA 90 and 9 out with the
championship Bulls on their back it's
almost like teams come at them like the
Warriors yeah yeah and be able to ask
young guys to come and Flemmi Kuzma the
second-year player might be your best
3-point shooter so you know I can adjust
it out as a coach I can take him out the
game and see who else can step up so I
don't seem to make up the playoffs
however with LeBron anything's possible
on his team but I do think they'll have
to make a trade to get a shooter or two
but that's what I wonder if they get to
a point where they're not playing well
and I'm not gonna say panic but you feel
like you have to make a move and then
they make a move at the trade deadline
now I I'm saying hey just enjoy this
year don't expect a lot just enjoy it
I don't know if because it's the Lakers
it's LeBron and magics there and they go
you know what we got to shake this up a
little bit here and then you run that
risk of do you get rid of some of these
younger kids and I'd be against that
what do you think
be careful Dan you're making sense so
you might lose some fans man because
that that's that's what should happen
you know Marv asked me what what would
be successful the team this year I said
it's time for LeBron James they've
already signed them the fans are back so
this year's you know if this is a four
year movie and you win two championships
out of it it doesn't matter when it
comes but you messed up the whole thing
when if you go out and panic maybe like
they did going to get out there Thomas
in Cleveland do you want that situation
again so I agree wholeheartedly and that
was my point of emphasis let these young
guys grow up Brandon England Kuzma these
young guys get to be around the bronze
for one whole year wait till next year
what happens if they do go get a Duran
or Kawhi you know someone like that so
I'm with you do not go out and panic
make sure that you get a nice free agent
booked to Lincoln magic I'm sure there
with that they're used to criticism and
fake criticism so hopefully there's
known then but again
yeah I think it's just going to be tough
for this team with their shooting and
the way that it's kind of their talent
to make the playoffs there was a report
over the weekend where there were there
was chatter I guess inside NBA with a GM
or players saying that LeBron has lost a
little bit of tread on the tires there
have you noticed anything about LeBron
that he's not the you know the old
LeBron he's just an old LeBron he's a
known LeBron and oh the still top three
in the NBA who's better than LeBron
so better is relative I don't know who's
better
who will make my whole team better I
don't know anyone that averages as many
points and assists as he does in the
league right now on only one James
Harden does yeah yeah but but he's not
as efficient and and he handles the ball
a little bit too much so uh man I mean
Durant to me is still is the best scorer
maybe that's a it's gonna be the best
score that the league is saying I still
see Curry but on defense you know if it
was just curry Tina carries on the
Charlotte it'd be hard for him to stop
of LeBron and be that defensive stopper
that LeBron could be at the end so
because of the size and knowledge I
still say there's there's no one better
but it's 15 feet of course you're not
gonna jump his high or he's not gonna
you know in the West Coast you run a lot
more and so he needs younger players to
help him take plays off like players
doing their fourth year of crime he just
has never been you know he's just never
been afforded that luxury and so you
know it's tough I don't know anyone I
would say that's better than LeBron but
there are a lot of players I would take
definitely because they can do so much
yeah you know we had Barclays on
Barclays said the James Harden if he
wanted to could average 50 again I don't
know about 50 but 42 to 45 he could
definitely get it I mean last night I
was watching him I've never seen
anything like I mean curry is so dynamic
with his speed and dribbling around and
doing you know it's best curly nearly
imitation is stepping back hitting the
crazy shot turn around before it goes in
Harlan is almost the opposite he's slow
and methodical he's gonna use the
pick-and-roll he's gonna attack your
front foot they're gonna say don't let
him go left and then he's gonna go right
like five times you're gonna forget he's
gonna go left for the rest of the game
he's such a great passer that little
ugly 19:45 layup that he does and then
that little concerning feel like the
alley-oop at the same time and you don't
know it then they'll come down and dunk
on you so harden is one of my favorite
players and I've been criticized for
having them be one of my favorite
players but I just don't know
defensively is a big man how you stopped
them I don't know how the guards how you
stopped on me his handles are incredible
and yet he gets to the line so
that's what we don't realize he's a
one-man fast break and so just the fact
that he did to the line he takes contact
he'd get 12 to 20 free throws a night oh
yes definitely
or if he was in Charlotte he could he
could average 45 on this team he could
but they wouldn't win a lot but in
Charlotte yeah definitely you could have
as close to fit yeah it is amazing when
you watch you know there's certain
players where you watch and you go I
just don't get how they do it Steve Nash
was always that way that if you if you
met Steve Nash you go how is that guy
doing it and and then you would see him
and Harden is like that with me too I
just watch and I go I don't get I know
what's coming and I can't do anything
about it can't do it this is like a
slow-motion all right did you know
allowed to say what early Jobs did give
him a blindfolded cigarette you know on
the play all night because you as a
defender you know it's you're at his
mercy his footwork is so good I mean
he's strong too he has a different body
you know his body seems like he doesn't
have a big chest he's not that much cos
he has big shoulders and he's very quick
he doesn't have to be fast but he's so
quickly explosive and you're right you
could know the play that's coming see it
put your hand in his face and it really
still doesn't matter this g-league
$125,000 coming out of high school the
elite players would you have done it I
don't know I had to think about that a
little bit more because it's a good
thing when I played like in high school
you know Isiah Thomas knows guys will
come all right to play against like
Derrick Coleman and Jim Carr st.
Cecilia's and shout out to everybody
saying Washington area by there but
there was like my G League so I remember
not to go to the story time Bartman
being like 14 and we got to play against
Derrick Coleman those guys and I
remember you know he's 19 20 I don't
know about him and I'm just destroying
us to where the fans after the game came
over consoled us and I remember going
that lock of life that was the best
beatdown ever look we can I can actually
shoot a layup all this guy can do this
it was like playing against them was
like okay this is how good I need to get
this what I need to do for next year and
I don't know if playing with a bunch of
guys with my skill set
425 would make me do that I can go
overseas and play against some great
players and better competition I think
it's about
the competition not necessarily who's
being babysat with you so I don't know I
really don't know the answer to that
question yet but I do know that when I
play being able to play against the pros
let me know how much further I had to go
and I don't see these guys getting to
play with the pros on the NBA team which
is just as good guys overseas or running
read getting ready to try to try to join
the team as a free agent so I'm not sure
about it but you could have come out of
high school and gone to the NBA if you
had that chance with your dad I blame
you Wow in this culture yes but coming
out like it was a sophomore it was the
scariest thing ever because I mean it's
a long time ago this was what 93 but
since then like 93 how was the first
sophomore to go number one since magic
is 79 so that's how long it had been
shacket waited to leave was junior
christian Laettner the best college
player in my and my 10-year plan or my
lifetime he had waited to the senior
year so it was such a different culture
that when when I left him it felt really
weird like you can go and you're ready
but you don't belong until you get to
this age so yesterday definitely his
culture has changed but back then that
would have been that was unheard of even
though again we were playing against the
pros in high school we just didn't we
didn't know that it was okay and
therefore it never really popped into my
mind but yeah I would definitely go
today if if I knew I was guaranteed to
be a top 7 pick good division with you
see Webb thanks for joining us as always
have fun tonight appreciate that's Chris
Webber for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]